thank you  a lot of weapons are defined by their  handle the handle is what connects the  user to the blade  because that's where it's going to break  that's where it's going to snap oh yeah  I don't care how beautiful your bait is  if your handle looks like it's going to  hurt me I'm not going to pick it up  Beyond making a proper handle you take a  katana blade that you mount it with the  handle from say a Burmese dog or you  have no guard that's going to change how  you fight with it because now that blade  can slide up onto your hand you can't  use that guard to stop a blade it's not  there it's going to change the weapon  it's going to change how it's used  by the handle changing you change every  aspect of that weapon how it's used in  defense and attack  handle often decides what that weapon is  [Music]